実は
大きな熊のぬいぐるみを買ったんですけども
今、下の玄関のほうに
引っ掛かっているんで
とりあえず、巨大な、熊のぬいぐるみをここまで
持ってきます、もう、その動画です
ただね、ほんとにね、ちょっとでかすぎて
引っ掛かってて動けねぇんだわ
おっ、おい
[BGM]
だ、駄目だ、完全に引っ掛かってやがる
おい、しっかりしろ、大丈夫か？！
（くまの声）;@[:/&$・・・たしゅけて、たしゅけて
、、、うん
あのですね、何か
こういう大きなくまのぬいぐるみは
コストコとかで買える、て話をよく聞くんですけども
僕はコストコ婚姻…
僕はコストコ会員でもないし
コストコに行ったこともありません
イケアでも売ってるって聞いたんですけど
そこにもないです
コストコもイケアも売り切れてるって
聞いたんですけど
俺はな、そういうなんか会員とか
めんどくさいからしない人です
静岡の近くの温泉に
このぬいぐるみが置いてあって
で、なんか店員さんに聞いたら
買えますよと言われて
その温泉で買いました
で、買ったんですけども～
温泉で見たやつより
全然大きくてなんか
玄関が通らないんですよ
とりあえずねこいつを
こっちの、は、もう、二階に運っびます
今日はこいつを
運び出すだけの動画だからね
よし（小声）
問題はどうやって運ぶかなんだよ
どーすればいいわけ
（効果音）キラリン～
ここで もう引っかかっちゃうんすよ。
ああっ
くそ・・・
どうしよう・・・ねえ、ちょっと、運べないんだけど。
横に、横にしてみようか。
（効果音）ヒューン
横ならいけそうだな。
[BGM]
あっ、いけた。横ならいける。
待って！・・・
これトイレに入るんじゃね？
普通にトイレには入るね。
トイレには、熊は いれるそうです。
よかったよかった。引き続き、上の部屋まで持っていきます。
はあ・・・はあ・・・重い
[BGM]
うあ～・・・おお・・・ちょっと待って
これキツくね？１人でするもんじゃないよ。
おお～し、お尻を・・・転がしていこう。
よいしょ
転がすしか方法は無いっすね、こりゃあ。
おらあ！行け行け！
はあっ・・・
よいしょ・・・
（ドアを開ける音）　よいしょ。
入れ！・・・よっしゃあ
ここまで来ればいけるでしょう
よしよしよし・・・
あとはここに立たせるだけだ。
よし、どうだ？
嘘お～？！
ちょっと待って待って・・・自立できないの、君？
ねえ、うおいっ
ねえ～！・・・立たない（笑）
お前さあ、え、ちょっと待って、どうすればいい？
立たないんですけど、こいつ。（殴る 効果音）
シングルは寂しいし、僕はよく東京とか行くので ペットとか飼えないので、ちょっと寂しいんですよ。
その寂しさを紛らわすために、今回ね、こちらの、
所沢を買ったわけですよ。
ちなみにこのぬいぐるみはね、座ってるときは160㎝くらいです。
立つと、2mを超えるって聞いたことが・・・
ありますっ！！
立つと2mを超えるらしいんですけど、足はフニャフニャなんで意味ないです。
あ、座った。
アマゾンでも売ってるのを見ました。なので、買おうと思えば普通に買えると思います。
わあああ～！
これね・・・これ、いいわあ。
ハッハッハッハッハ！
寂しい新居だったんですけども・・・やっとね、オリジナリティが出たと思います。
熊の所沢・・・
（殴る 効果音）
（ゴングの音）
（エンディング曲）